WHE SUBMERSIBLE TIT WENT OA  W
ITWEE
EL ITSELF THESTIONS
RR THE SION TO BUIL OF
CARBON COMPOSITE AND NOT CERTIFY
ITS SAFE AS OTHER SUESSELS
EA EXPLORER AND
OR JAMES
CAMERON.
IT'S EXTRAORNAME THAEBY FROM TH
"TITANIC."
OBVIOUSLY, PEOPLE THINK OF THE
YOUR LM "TI
ON THE
BOW.
I HEARD YOU  OTA
TWO CAPTAINS AND
F TY THAT YOU
SE
AND I'M WONDERING OU
'S
AN ICE FIELDGHK BECA STEAM INTO
MOONLESS NIGHTITAFTER HE HADN RE
GRY Y TELEGRAM BMARCON
AND I THWEE ALSO SEEING A
PARALLEL HERE WITH UNHEEDED
WARNINBO THA
T ERE TH
DEEP SUBMEENCE COM
NOT E TIRENITY
OF THEM GOT
A LETTERO
OCEANGATHENY, AN
TOAT.ESS  IS CLD
BUT IT CON TEM PLAIPTED THE FACT
PROBLEM DNPAFI
BUREAU.
HEAD
THIS WHOLE
NIGHTMARE.MEE IT P MYSELF AT SB
ISI IS
OBVIOUE SPECTER THAT LOOMSS TIMH
E
MOSTS IN.
SO THAT SHOULD NEVER BPROBLEM.
BE IMPLOOU BELWAG TO HAVE A SERU
MAYBE ENTANGLEMENT IN A FISHING
HARD TO RUSE THINGS OS
F
ELEMENAN  DESIGN.
>> DO YOT - WHAT LEARN
BECAUSVIDEEP WATER
EXPLOR THERE'S APRETTY GREAT --
SAFETY RECOR PEOPLE WHO E CERTI
PEDIED
THIS.
>> IT'S -
>> DU
HA IMPACT ON THE CONTINUED
EXOR
IIED ABOUT
EXCAUSE WILL GO.D I'M WO
PEOPLE WILL
INNOI'M WORRIED THAT IHAA
, LESAY,
TI
OWS PEOPLE TH SER
THAT.ESE PLA TOURAGE
BUT I K THATT'S ALMO
THE  YOU'REO VEHICLE,S AN
THROUGH CERTIFYING AGENCIES.
, THAT IT' SIGNE
SOMEBODY SOMEWHERE HAS DONE THE
MARO ALL BEEN
RTERLY.
WED TAKE THE SAM
WE'RE 0 FEET
TRITON. A PARTNEMPY
ATRITONAND TRITON HAS A PCT
OPERATIONAL SAFETY RECD
PEOPLE DIVIN DS UP TO 1,000 MET.
E DONES RI UIN THEMM NOW OURPENE
WHD LARGELY,KNOW, ITS US NOW O
MORE ALERT TO BE DISCIPLEDEAY
OF IT.
YOU KNOW, THERWHE .
NOT GOING TO HAVE
GU EVERYWHS PROBLEM.
Y MOREWEND PCTE DON'ENOPT
A.B.S. OR GERMAN L
WHATEVON.HE REAADDAY WAS LKT TH
CAN YOU  TALK ABOUT THAT
FEOWN HO
VE GONE INTO THECE
THREE TIMEHAN TH THINK YOUAID.
EAH.
T IS THAFE
GO D WEN 'D HAVETOA BACKSHOW WI
ON THIS  REMOTENS.I HERE WAS NPO
NO
IN THE WORLD NO MATTER IF YOU
COULD FL NER IF I  ENOUGH  M WA
AND HO ABOUT THAT FOR
BUILNG.GNED A LOT OF THE
WAS GOING TO BE IN THAT SUB IN
TERMS OFOW T THE WEIGHTS, IF I A
E UL EMLV
ME.
BEACONS  GOTK TO
THRFAC HADRI
SAIT WLD
TION.
I HAD D VI BEACONS.
IT WOULDN'T HA
AIRCRAFT SEARCH.
QUICKLY.ME PRETTY
SO YOU THINK ALL THAT STUFF
T T,OSED
NO EE JU  AANTI
YOU' LT SOME
NO BEEN THAT WAY
OT
YEARS.
TRAGY.OW, AND K THAT'SRE WHY PE
TO GO ANPET FOR
THEMSE.
TO RE HISRYYOU KNOW.THINK PEOPG
GTY
YOU KNOW, NORMANDY
THOSE THGSREMEMB
E IT IN AND MAKE
PART OF THEIVES.
I DON'IN- I DON'T
S ANYT
MET KE
GTH
THING.
ORO
BUT HERE'SE Y
REMEMB TITANIC, TIVE WE DIDN'T
BECAUSE THE ARROGANCANIS THAT SA
ITS DOOM IEXTHINE OP S IT'S REA
WE'RE TALKIN